uh let's get to today's topic which is
stoicism and marriage
we have as
guests
two people who are both stoic
practitioners and in fact married to
each other
and so this is going to be an
interesting conversation um we have
andy shiaka who is an associate
professor of humanities at the milwaukee
institute of art and design the ceo of
women's entrepreneurship week and an
associate for accreditation and
licensing for the european graduate
school where she is also a doctoral
candidate in philosophy
andy serves in leadership positions for
several non-profit organizations
and enjoys mentoring emerging leaders in
food system innovation and
sustainability efforts
greg
greg sadler is a philosopher who brings
that discipline to practical
professional and public settings he's
editor of stoicism today
producer and co-host of the wisdom for
life radio show and founder of the half
hour eagle project
he teaches at the milwaukee institute of
art and design and is the president of
reason i owe a company putting
philosophy into practice and he is the
first returning guest of this show
i believe in fact rob wasn't even on
board uh when the first time that craig
was was around that's right right yeah
so that time i think we we talked about
um
common misunderstandings of stoicism and
today we're going to talk about marriage
welcome andy and greg
thank you it's great to be here
yeah i think we probably will also talk
about some misunderstandings of stoicism
[Laughter]
so let me start with an obviously easy
and and um yet i think interesting
question which is how is it that the two
of you got into stoicism in the first
place and how did you get married
well i'll start healthy questions
i'll start and then and then greg can
you get i think um because for me
greg is the reason that i am involved in
stoicism um
i
we went to high school together and
there's a whole long story there that
i'm sure greg will will give pieces and
bits um but when we
met or re-met or reconnected
uh greg was living in north carolina i
was in new york um
he moved up to where i was
in the hudson valley and we ended up in
this very tiny space two big people with
two big dogs and two cats and these
seven thousand books
um and i was living like on a hippie
farm above a garage in a carriage house
apartment
and i didn't enjoy my job very much at
the time but it was you know the better
kind of paying of the two and you know
we had some long conversations about
what it meant for our relationship long
term and
and our decision to get married but um i
was under extreme duress i think we
could say and a lot of stress
and because of where we were in the
country it would be
you know the place i worked was actually
directly across from where we lived in
kingston uh across the river and yet
there were only two bridges on either
side and so i would have to drive 45
minutes down to get the bridge and then
another 45 minutes back up to get to my
workplace and wow you know it was a
grueling assignment
um i mistakenly thought that you know
the the kind of advancement into
administration as a dean when i had been
teaching was the right thing to do and
discovered that my worst day teaching is
still better than my best day doing
anything else
and you could not pay me enough to be
the dean um but i discovered that too
late after i'd already accepted the
position so um
there was an upcoming course of the
stoic mindfulness and resilience
training and stoic week and all these
things you know and greg said hey listen
i think we should do this i think it
would help i think there's a lot that
you could take away um i've said before
that i always thought that the thing i
needed to do was learn how to control
the sun and then my life would be so
much better
and what i realized through stoic
practice is that actually that's not the
case for me at all i do not get you know
i i'm not served well by my past
controlling tendencies which i'm sure
greg and i can both agree are passed
only and so much as they're they're not
on display right now you know i mean
it's a constant constant process but um
yeah i have found it changed my life
positively in ways that i never could
have anticipated and definitely has had
positive impact on our relationship on
our marriage on my relationship with
others
um but that's my story and then in terms
of you know kind of how we got together
and
got married and decided to continue
doing this sort of practice together
i'll let actually greg speak to that
right yes
so there's a lot of different moving
parts to that i'll say that um
i ended up getting into stoicism in a
serious way as opposed to like having
encountered it and tried a little bit of
it and then you know uh abandoned it
quickly enough which which happened when
i was an undergraduate you know and had
to read some marcus aurelius and some
epictetus and really like the toughness
part the lower case s stoic and ignored
all the stuff about virtue
you know all the really important things
um
it was through
looking to ancient philosophy for
resources having to do with anger
management which was an area that i
started doing a lot of research in in
graduate school and i still do today
and i i was motivated first to look at
you know aristotle and plato and and
some of the later plagueness and then i
started to see
how much
there was in stoicism in terms of
resources in epictetus and seneca until
to a lesser degree in marcus just
because we don't have that much of his
his stuff
and that sucked me in to
taking um the philosophy seriously and
then
i started you know doing more and more
writing on it and then i became or i
think around the same time as massimo
involved in the at that time it wasn't
actually called the modern stoicism
organization because there wasn't an
organization i think it was just called
stoicism today
and
then you know when
one of the things that's kind of cool
about this both with
the modern socialism organization
and with my my relation with andy is
when you're when you're doing this stuff
and you're not doing it
by yourself but in conversation with
other people you learn a lot more and
you can bounce ideas off of each other
and so
you know both with with you know massimo
and all the other people chris gill
who's you know it's kind of like getting
to meet a rock star uh if you're an
academic researcher an ancient
philosophy you know donald roberts and
all these other people we could mention
we would you know bounce ideas off of
each other
and learn from each other and then with
with andy and i
um we're doing something quite quite
similar and so i think that my
development in stoicism has been greatly
aided by
engaging with other people
you know the other stuff i'll say about
the marriage thing
so
we actually got married on the way to
work
and
it was uh it was supposed to be a very
matter-of-fact kind of thing
a little bit of backstory you know when
when
states like new york passed
legislation that allowed for domestic
partnerships we did that and we did that
so i could have insurance and you know
just in case i got sick because andy had
insurance and i didn't and then the
government came along and said well
that's taxable
and so very being very practical people
we were like well i guess we better get
married i mean we were gonna get married
anyway because we'd fallen in love and
we'd moved in together and and you know
we're beginning our whole life together
but we we also did decide well it needs
to happen soon and so
we better before the next tech cycle
exactly it really was
and our 10-year anniversary is coming up
very very soon
and so we we literally went to the
township of a sopas and
there's a marriage officer there and and
she did this ceremony and and uh then we
went on our way to work i was teaching
at marist college at the time and andy
was working at the culinary
and um
you know it's kind of i think a lot of
people get into
weddings and they do a lot of big
production kind of stuff
in a way it might be better to make it
very
short and matter of fact because
neither way do you really know what
you're getting into at the start right
you have to you have to grow with it and
it is an unknown anyway
the one thing i'll end on because i
don't want to take up too much time is
if you really do a lot of like planning
and ceremony and stuff like that the
emphasis tends to be on that
that day and that
that time as if that's going to set
everything
on the right path afterwards and and
instead marriage is continually it
really does require the stoic virtue of
courage which a major portion of which
is perseverance right and perseverance
is making the right decisions
or unmaking your wrong decisions over
and over and over
again right
so
um yeah that's a good way to put it yeah
absolutely yeah like that
rob i think you have that yeah and i i
just wanted to um
you know as long as we're talking about
this a little bit my wife and i uh this
next year are going to be celebrating
our 30th anniversary oh wow
congratulations um
and
you know so some of the questions i'm
going to ask are kind of inspired by
that
but i also wanted to bring it back to
sort of some of the sort of specifically
stoic ideas and some of the texts and
places where i get pushback from people
who i talk to and stuff
um but first one one of the things that
comes up with a lot of
related topics to relationships and
stuff like that is is there a difference
and if so what between the way say the
greek stoics talked about relationships
in marriage and the roman stoics right
so people will point sometimes to for
example the ideas of
uh
you know women and children held in
common and supposedly in zeno's republic
and then you get say mussonius rufus's
rather sort of um
almost victorian sort of talk about sex
and marriage and relationships and uh i
wonder if you
had something to say about that
either you guys
well um i mean andy is there anything
you want to say before i this is the
only thing that i'll say is that i
probably wouldn't add much value to the
conversation in part because when i was
asked the question about whether or not
stoicism could be good for
women my answer was women are people and
stoicism is good for people so i don't
understand the question
um
so with that said i think you know when
it comes to scholarship greg is
definitely the person to turn to but i i
i do think that
as a
woman who practices
um any kind of uh sort of philosophical
thought i'm always kind of just placing
myself into the text and positions that
feed me
rather than
you know starve me out of the
conversation um but with that said greg
i yeah why don't you take it from there
yeah so i think there's a couple things
to say i mean one is we really have
almost nothing of the
early greek stoics or or the middle
stoics on these matters at least and i
don't know how much we can read into the
the remarks about the republic i mean
what we know is that zeno and clianthes
and chrysippus wrote
texts that are recorded in the titles of
which are recorded in diagonalities that
are very tantalizing for you know
what they're they're saying because you
know dialogues about love and stuff like
that but we have nothing from that so
it's it's hard to say what the contrast
is and and the irony too is that
a lot of our roman stoics are actually
writing in greek you know uh epictetus
smithsonius
marcus
and and we you know we we do know a good
bit about
stoic ethics
um from seneca and also from
cicero writing in latin
on the topic of um marriage mussonius
yeah he has some things to say and it's
interesting because a lot of people
who want to use mussonius
because they're cultural conservatives
they will focus in on you know marriage
is for procreation right and then
immediately after that he starts
spelling out this marriage as a
friendship and um i i he doesn't of
course use a word like intimacy because
there isn't there isn't a word for that
but i think that mussonius actually fits
into this um
this uh current that we see in ancient
philosophy
and i i don't want to say that it didn't
exist among the hellenistic greeks but
it's definitely there
in
roman times where marriage comes to be
considered
as something that in the middle ages
will get
you know brought out even more by these
these monks who are reading cicero and
seneca and and um
you know authors like that where a
marriage is supposed to exist for
multiple reasons there's there's the
pleasure that spouses can take in each
other
and that can be through
um how they you know use their sexuality
but it can be a whole bunch of other
things too
and you know a marriage that's formed on
that basis from a stoic perspective is
probably on on thin ice
making kids that's nice a lot of
marriages don't produce kids you know
so that can't be the sole purpose
but the friendship that
love eros or philia produces
that's something considered really
valuable and
you know
it becomes what what what gets called in
the middle ages conjugal love and i
think that mussonius kind of fits into
that tradition and i think stoicism
should emphasize that in in the present
and it doesn't have to be just marriages
we can think of other
committed partnered relationships um
along similar lines so i don't know if
that fully answers greg i want to pick
you your brain about this um then
specifically staying on muzonius from
yeah yeah right because masonis is as
you say it can be
interpreted in a very sort of modern
conservative fashion or in almost a
feminist fashion i mean after all it
does explicitly say women have the same
ability as as men uh they should learn
you know virtue because what human being
you know going back to andy's comment
about women men and human beings in
general what human being cannot possibly
you know be uh
you know improved by by practicing
virtue yeah not only that but he
actually chastises
uh men and says you know you want your
women to be uh chaste and and all that
and and reserved but you guys go around
and do whatever the hell you want it's
like how does that work so so there's a
lot of modern uh or modern sounding at
least uh language in there but then
there is also the thing about yeah sex
is
only within marriage and for procreation
which epictetus also repeats yeah
so there was a paper that i read
two or three years ago
uh and this was a technical paper and i
have i will have to look up the the
authors but um about uh stoicism and and
feminism so in gen in general and the
interesting idea i thought that the the
authors presented was like okay
we can go there and and analyze and
reanalyze what seneca amusonus and all
that people write specifically about
they may or may not sound feminist from
modern perspective but the bottom line
is
that the really important question is
whether stoicism is a philosophy
regardless of what any particular stoic
that actually written
entails or doesn't entail
something like uh feminism feminism here
very simple yeah feminism simply
understood as you know the notion the
radical notion is sometimes put that
women and men are you know both human
beings and therefore they they deserve
the same rights and and privileges etc
etc if you understand feminism in a
minimalist way that in that way then the
question is
well seneca may or may not qualify
nozoni's mayor may not qualify but then
again they are it's difficult to tell
apart their own
cultural milieu and time and place from
the philosophy but the philosophy itself
one could argue that does or is is or is
not friendly to certain certain notions
so
just off the cuff of the
what do you think if i say stoicism and
feminism what what comes to mind both of
you andy feel free to jump in any any
time
do you want to take that one andy or
right off i think i'll respond because
i'd love to hear what you say
[Laughter]
sounds good as your pal as your wife no
i'm just kidding um yeah i i would love
to hear what you say though yeah i'll
respond on that one because i we both
know that i have strong feelings about
it so
oh you won't hear what i say first okay
yeah yeah um well yeah i think i think
yeah because that's why she can you know
criticize you for what it is that you're
about to say
so i'll say i'll say two things one is
that um i think what you're saying
massimo is is completely right that
if we understand feminism in terms of
what's often called equality feminism
often associated with like first and
second wave thinkers like you know mary
wollstonecraft great virtue ethicist
right um and also a great exemplar of of
the virtues more or less herself
um i think stoicism is very congenial to
that and it in our current context it
would be
promoting it just as we
you know if you're if you're a stoic um
i think that if you really take the the
philosophy seriously
you know you can't be a racist
um if you are if you find racist
tendencies within yourself stoicism
would tell you
need to root those out one thing i'll
point out too that one of the examples
of the indifference
for the classic stoics is the color of a
person's skin
you know so that that should be uh
useful for that the the other thing i'll
say is um and i think this is something
that that andy will probably
go off of as well
the things that stoicism has to say
about
marriage or about gender and sexuality
or
about about any of these things
it's it's not as if there's like a
special stoic doctrine about this and
then a special stoic doctrine about that
they're you know it's a general
philosophy
and
it is a complex one so it's not as if
there's like two axioms that you work
off of and everything falls into place
but
um
you know
so let's think about this in terms of
like gender roles within a marriage
um
yes massonius is is very
uh progressive in our current sense
but he still does think that men and
women are are somewhat different in the
roles that they would inhabit within you
know uh households but we don't have to
be bound to that at all you know we can
say well that is that is a just a
manifestation of his cultural situation
epictetus is is a bit well not a bit
he's much more
about traditional gender roles guys need
to have beards for example
um
and so philosophers need a beer that's
right well men men period ought to have
a beard so massimo you're in trouble i
know
i just shaved recently
before um uh before we go on i actually
looked up the paper that i just
mentioned
by scott eichen and emily mcgill
rutherford and it was published in
symposium in 2014 with the title
stoicism feminism and autonomy so if
people are interested and want to look
it up it's it's really it's really well
done because as i said the uh the thesis
that they put forth is like look if you
look at individual ancient stoics they
have a mixed record when it comes to
women uh you know they say some things
that are way ahead of their time
uh or or at least on par with things
that epicurus was saying for instance
because epicureanism also was uh you
know friendly to women as a philosophy
uh but generally ahead of their time and
then other things they're like no you
you cringe you cringe today it's like
you know especially when you keep
reading seneca and says oh don't be
womanly don't be you know this and that
is like no that's obviously not
acceptable but they said the
really interesting important question
is
does stoicism as a philosophy have the
tools
for endorsing a robust version of
feminism and and they agree with your
what would you just said that the answer
is positive
uh and in particular that answer comes
out of the notion that while the stoics
are cosmopolitan
that's true too yeah right and and uh
and for the stoics anybody who is
capable of reason
uh is uh
ought to be treated with justice
and it seems extremely knowledge yeah go
ahead
uh i do want to hear what andy has to
say in response but i it's sort of
attention to this do you think that
a commitment to cosmopolitanism
means
like looking across cultures and saying
well
here's where we can say that like gender
roles really do vary from culture to
culture to culture and so we don't need
to be beholden to hellenistic greek or
you know traditional roman or you know
pick whatever else
cosmopolitanism would mean
not a sort of relativism but but at
least a sort of recognition that many of
these things are just culturally
conditioned
well i mean if i can follow up on that
point i've been
thinking i mean how i think this is a
related question right is how much of
this can we fully separate
from the cultural context in which
they've come up right it's not as though
like we can read mussonius and say
well that's this sentence is pure
stoicism this sentence is cultural
conditioning right nor can we do right
so so
i wonder if we can separate that in a
way that's robust enough to ground the
idea that there is a stoicism that
entails
uh you know first or second wave
feminism for example or something yeah i
mean you might so it's more about
mapping it mapping it on i mean i'm just
listening to what massimo said about you
know whether or not there's a mixed
record i think there's a mixed record on
most areas of philosophy i mean greg
talks about this about what aristotle
would say where he alive now about his
position on women and i think that as a
as a woman who's operating in the world
as a woman
you're constantly having to map on
things i mean it's not like i'm reading
epictetus or i'm reading someone and i
get to a point i'm like oh i'm supposed
to not do that i better not like there's
no prescriptive prescriptive sense of
myself in this writing or this reading
or this reflecting
and you know between the two of us and i
hope greg doesn't mind me saying this
but he is by far the more emotionally
sensitive partner and that doesn't make
me a bad woman we're not gender
essentialists in our house we look at
the kind of pathways that we're on and
figure out sort of you know
where we might better support one
another and that's an ongoing process in
any relationship in particular in a
marriage um but you know when it comes
to the kinds of like nurturing things
that's much more his camp than mine and
i've learned how to be more nurturing as
as a part of my relationship with him um
you know i'm the one who was like let's
go to the marriage officer let's sign
this thing i went to an academic affairs
meeting after people were like oh didn't
you want a wedding and i said no i
catered them they're ridiculously
expensive and why would i ever spend
that money we could put that into land
we could put that into books we could
put that into travel right so
i think that if you were to take a step
back and say oh andy's you know a woman
and yet she's so different in these ways
you would be prescribing to that very
sense of restriction that we're trying
to move away from i'm a human i use
stoicism as a human i'm married to
someone who is engendered as a man i'm
engendered as a woman
that's also our biological sex and we
just kind of go about the business of
our day
now it doesn't mean that there aren't
things that
i think are kind of in our marriage that
maybe support
certain traditional gender roles but
it's not because we feel assigned to
them or limited by them it's because we
choose them for ourselves because we're
thinking feeling beings with autonomy
and i think that there's a lot of
conversation and it's important and i
don't mean to imply that it's not
reflecting on the past and the thinkers
and the history
and the literature
and you know all of these things about
the placement of women and as a woman
who operates in the world right now as
as a person of agency i would say
yes
and how do we deal with that now right
because how are we as stoics or people
who are practicing stoicism or people
who are just trying to be kinder to one
another to not be racist to not be
sexist to not be jerks how are we using
tools from philosophical thought to
strengthen our ability to be better
human beings that is always my
orientation
um and i i'm not suggesting that the
conversation isn't important but my
question is
what if it's not what if it's not there
does that mean that we don't practice it
do we have to find instances that we can
point to i don't think so
right um
but at the same time i do understand
again i'm not in any way suggesting that
this isn't good to do
but as somebody who's often left out of
the conversation if i look at it
historically i don't care i don't care
that i'm left out of the historical
conversation my concern is how am i
involved in the conversation of the
present how do i apply you know the
various disciplines how do i
move away from
bad habits or bad behaviors and learn
from what's there for me uh to use to do
that
whether or not someone was able to do
that a thousand years ago is probably um
you know relevant only in so much is
that i can say i wish that that had not
been the case but i could apply that to
numerous categories throughout history
based on where we are and what period of
history we're talking about
right
right
yeah um no yeah i think it's good i mean
you're highlighting right
um
some really important things about how
we read these ancient texts and and um
what we take out of them and i think
that's i think that's um
important to reflect on as we do it
um
let me let me remind the audience that
um they can uh post questions in the
chat and then at some point we might
pick a couple two or three depending on
how much time we have yeah sorry uh rob
go ahead yeah right um i wanted to ask
you guys about um
about the text
right
um and in particular about encouraging
three
which is the i'm fond of a jug passage
right uh so
right when epictetus says right so uh
you know
so i'm fond of a jug right if you
remember that and that jugs are the sort
of things that break
uh then when your jug breaks you won't
be upset about it and then he
immediately goes to and then say that
when you kiss your wife or your child
right that they're a human being
um and he doesn't say this right but i
think they obviously implication is that
they're going to die and then you won't
be upset right or no he does say that in
the message and i always get whenever i
talk about that passage i always get a
ton of pushback about like how cold
callous and uncaring is that right yeah
that you know people want to throw away
their books or whatever at this point
and so i wonder what you guys had to say
about that passage now i i yeah what do
you think you know when you've kissed
each other and a good night and night
are you thinking and you know i know you
might not be here tomorrow morning but
hey what the hell well frankly we're
such workaholics that when we
hit the bed we're both exhausted and are
not thinking of much of anything but i
will say this i've i've had i i always
got so much pushback that i actually
wrote a piece a while back specifically
about
that passage and you know how to
interpret it i think it's important that
the fond being fond of there is
philostergia right so it's the familial
affection that you're supposed to feel
towards towards people
um
and you know it can be children can be
your spouse
it's not just like fondness it's
you love them and so epictetus is
acknowledging that you do in fact love
them and i think that one of the ways in
which people
often get mixed up and this is a larger
topic about grief is they think that if
they don't feel
[Music]
terrible grief when somebody
goes then they didn't really love them
and the stoics would say no those are
not connected with each other at all
ideally
if if somebody dies
i mean you could especially if they're a
child you say oh there's way too young
and this is unfortunate their their life
was snuffed out
but you don't have to see it as like the
end of the world
um you know i think that epictetus is
also isn't saying
when your spouse dies it's going to be
just like a jug breaking
you know that's not the implication of
the passage it he is telling us there's
like three and i don't remember the
exact greek terms but it's things that
you're fond of things i think you find
useful
and then there's one other one that i'm
trying to bring to mind but so it's
covering a wide range of of stuff that
we should have a different response to
but yeah people find that pretty pretty
cold and callous
it doesn't have to be interpreted that
way that it can be contained that that
also comes from uh to some extent at
least it is connected to stoic
metaphysics
uh even though that's a bit of ethics
right meaning for instance because
because let's remember that for the
ancient stoics not necessarily for the
modern ones but for the ancient stoics
the universe is uh you know living
organism with literally bits and pieces
of it and everything we do is in fact
and everything that happens to us is for
the good of the organism when epictetus
uses the the famous analogy of the foot
that has to cross the the muddy path
right so if you see things that way
uh then there is actually quite a bit of
um
solace that you can you can take from
from that from that view of the of
providence in a sense this is not
providence in the christian sense of the
term but it's still a kind of providence
it's still like well
i may not understand it it might hurt me
and in my i might not like it just like
if i were a foot having to cross you
know to step into the mud but if i
remember that this is all part of a
whole
shebang that is going on and that the
shebang itself is good uh then i
actually should be you know should be
happy about it not not even that's why
he says
in more than one occasion he says that
we shouldn't just embrace it you know
just accept it you shouldn't embrace it
you should actually
you know go with it i mean i think you
can do that right i don't think that's
in that passage no not in that passage
right yeah um i thought you were going
to go with like talking about like how
marcus over and over and over again
reminds himself listen things break down
you know you're going to break down and
you know going going back to marriage so
there's
there's
not just the fact that either andy's
going to die before me or i'm going to
die before her we're going to die at the
same time
which in some ways would be ideal
because uh you know then you don't have
to like worry about anything
afterwards it's just over
exactly
but we also have to think about the the
relationship itself is something that's
continually in flux and probably
you know
a marriage is like any other
relationship like a strong friendship or
a business partnership
it's something that you can't simply
take for granted as remaining exactly
the same and so a stoic metaphysic point
of view
on it might actually be helpful in that
respect because you're more attentive to
the fact that
um if you don't you know re-tune things
every once in a while or anticipate you
know andy's parents are still alive um
that's part of why we move back here to
wisconsin other you know than the fact
that we love it here and we're from here
um and sooner you know they're probably
there's a good chance they're gonna
they're gonna die before
her and then she's going to be in in
considerable grief and i'm gonna have to
be there to comfort her and help her out
and
um
you know that's also part of the
a relationship like that you know i
think though too i mean
my my kids give her give give us some
some grief as well so it's not just her
parents
go ahead andy i think what we were
saying though rob about that passage is
you know that's the first time i
actually encountered difficulty in what
we were doing and discussing inner stoic
fellowship because i really struggled
with that and it was very early on in my
understanding of kind of the larger
picture but it was so helpful to work
through it and to understand that it is
not coldness it is not any of those
things is an awareness of of
time passing and i look at someone like
catherine cormilas who's you know doing
the stoic death com contemplation she
just did for stokon she's gonna do it
again for women's entrepreneurship week
as a form of helping people think about
you know how to frame their lives but we
had those two big dogs and they became
senior dogs and we took such good care
of them that they lived far beyond their
breed's life expectancy and so it was
kind of like any day could be the day
but i found myself channeling that and
saying you know to them like you've been
such good dogs to me and i i you know i
care for you i mean when they died i was
gutted i was devastated those were my
children he had human children i had
these these beasts but i loved these
feasts and
were it not for understanding that it
was inevitable i think that i would have
treated their age and their aging
process and their decline very
differently it became part of what was
the natural course of things and
therefore i could process it
continuously it wasn't like one day i
was surprised by their loss and i talk
to people who kind of think in those
terms you know that everything is fine
until it's not and i don't know that
that's really emotionally very useful
um so i went from being very opposed to
that you know kind of passage to
actually embracing that passage as part
of what has brought me great value when
i'm with my parents i'm thinking of the
fact that i should notice certain things
like i should notice you know my dad has
these italian plum trees and you know
it's like his thing and it's been his
thing since i was a kid and he was
making jam just months ago and i i kind
of watched it and paid special attention
and said this is part of the experience
of my dad in this world
and
you know this jam
is part of who he is and i was able to
appreciate it differently recognizing
that there aren't so many summers where
his jam will still be made and it was
beautiful you know
so i i i do think that that's a tough
thing with greg
and me
you know ideally we do die at the same
time because that's there's a lot there
but that's on your marriage you know and
and yet i do think massimo i do say
often now much more often than in the
beginning
this is a person this is a human this
person brings me value this person
brings me comfort i care about this
person i will miss this person when
they're gone i'll miss you know all of
these things were i to be the one who
who was left
uh living after after something would
happen to greg and
it changes the way that i appreciate
him in the moment and in the present and
i think if that's a value that any kind
of partner can take whether it's a
business partner or a marriage partner
that's a great thing
to you know to see that person and
understand that this is now and you can
only really have this now now
you know
yeah that's great i really um i like
that i find that passage actually quite
comforting um yeah
in surprising ways right
really helps you appreciate those
i wanted to follow up and then with one
more um and then maybe we can get to
some of the questions from the audience
um
uh this question is actually sort of
inspired by my wife so uh we'll see um
and it's about kind of the dichotomy of
control right the idea that some things
are up to us and some things aren't
and a lot of times in stoic context
people might take
take advantage of this and say look you
know you can't upset me with because
your opinion is up to you or your belief
is up to you and mine is up to me right
um yeah but given that marriage is
typically
filled with
joint projects
right how is that sort of thinking
compatible or not
right isn't is is it compatible with the
sort of shared project that marriage
itself is or even you know things like
how do we run the household right who
feeds the dogs i've got two big dogs too
so i'm sympathetic to that right and
isn't that precisely the sort of thing
in which the
things that are technically not up to us
right the opinions of others for example
really do matter
and
are they really indifferent so i'd be
interested in your take on that
well i i think that there's a lot of
indifference that we shouldn't be
indifferent to um and epictetus says
that in his
chapter on on indifference uh euphoria
our uses of things are racist the way
that we deal with them they may be out
strictly speaking outside of our control
but he says we still have to be
concerned with them
and
i think when you're
this is this is something where maybe
the the apparatus that we have from
classical stoicism doesn't do enough to
help us out but i i think we can think
of our pro-races
as overlapping um when when we're in
relationships and it could be a marriage
or it could also be a very uh long
friendship as well that's very correct
um
not everybody that is following us yeah
might be familiar with the term
something central for
for epictetus uh it means the faculty of
choice you know the locus that we have
when we talk about the dichotomy of
control
the
the faculty of choice sometimes it's
also translated as moral purpose a
somewhat misleading translation is will
in some other translations because it
does cover a lot of what we call the
will but not not exactly
all of it
it's it's the thing it's the the place
where we get to make choices where we
actually can determine things
and it works upon itself and and you
know and again in a marriage we work
upon each other
um so
if andy if it's very important for her
that something happens
and i'm like well that's out of my
control you know i don't have to be
concerned with it at all you know i mean
i see rob laughing there he knows what
that's gonna what that's going to entail
right anybody who's in a relationship
knows how good that works out
we have to be kind of responsive to each
other's
um
needs and another thing too is stoicism
like any intentional way of life that's
that's based on virtue ethics is about
taking us as
screwed up
uh people who aren't even sure how
screwed up we are
and using you know things like our
capacity to choose to make ourselves
cumulatively bit by bit less and less
screwed up it's not about like having a
bunch of you know perfect rules for
perfect behavior that we then follow
it's not about having a number of axioms
it's about like this continual process
of
of of unscrewing ourselves up and we can
do that together
um
you know
ideally if you have a partner
who's um
you know bought into that you can you
can work on it together and then
sometimes you know andy helps me out by
saying hey man you're screwing up you
know
you need to you need to rethink this
thing that you've said because uh this
justification that you're given it's bs
and i don't know what's going on with
your mentality now
my bs is within my
my you know uh
realm of control right but sometimes it
takes somebody else coming in from the
outside saying man you're screwing up
uh for me to be able to actualize that
i think too though that's a a level of
respect and trust that we've built over
the years because i did
absolutely um there were times where
you know and and i'm i'm not proud of
this by any means but like greg would
come to me and say something about
perhaps something i said or a way that i
behaved that impacted him negatively and
i would say well that's your choice
right
now that that is a a big thing i think
it can be stoicism can be abusive
when we impose it on other people and
we're like oh i don't have any control
over your feelings i may have insulted
you
and like throwing thrown your stuff out
or you know ruined your plans but i
don't control your feelings i mean we
have to recognize that we have
responsibility go ahead sorry well i
think that's the thing no it's okay i
mean that that's precisely the kind of
thing that is is you know evidence of of
the hard work it takes to be in
partnership
because i can recognize now that that
was a move it was it was an area where i
was trying to control the situation by
saying something that i thought would
you know distance me from responsibility
and
you know there are so many things i
think that i've learned about myself and
the way that i was brought up to operate
in the way that i chose to operate in
the world that have benefited from this
kind of study and this kind of
engagement but you know
i'm actually at a point now where i
wouldn't have imagined that i could be
before where greg can do that the same
thing and bring it to me and say you're
about to mess this up
you know because here's how you're
looking at it and i might say something
like okay thank you for that feedback
i'm going to think about that whereas
andy two years ago would have
immediately like pedaled to the metal
gotten into a very defensive argument
because as you can probably tell we're
both very strong personalities and we
both are in fields where we have a
certain sense of intellectual authority
and it's something that we both really
enjoy our relationship truly is of the
mind of the spirit of the heart of the
body like i have my perfect partner in
greg but it's a lot of work and i'm a
lot of work i am no easy partner
and i know that but we've been able to
use what we've you know kind of gained
from these types of conversations to
build bridges where there were maybe
gaps but also to take down some walls
because i think both of us you know
brought some some resistance into our
marriage and in addition to building
positive uh
kind of habits of behavior and patterns
and even emotions toward one another um
we've definitely removed things that
were problematic to happiness
or joy or to living in accordance with
nature you know yeah but in in this
particular case that we're talking about
the preferred indifference and whether
something is up to you or not up to you
i i agree with with
you know pretty much everything you guys
said in the last few minutes however i
do wonder whether in this particular
case uh the problem isn't really mostly
with language the language of stoicism
in particular in the way in which
certain terms are translated often in
english because after all the stoics
when they when they talk about
something being indifferent they don't
mean that you shouldn't give a crap they
just mean that it doesn't affect you as
a moral person and that is true
uh regardless of you know if uh if andy
uh says something then that greg mayer
may not agree or not whatever andy says
doesn't change doesn't affect greg's
virtue
but that doesn't mean that he's
therefore entitled to ignore it or to
say i don't give a crap about this
because that actually would affect is
his virtue if he's the kind of person
that says i don't give a crap that
actually is that's not a virtuous
response so in some sense when we say
things like you know it's indifferent
we don't mean that we shouldn't care we
just mean that
well whatever he or she thinks this
isn't
you know this isn't undermining me as a
person and that actually thinking that
way actually helps uh you know say don't
take it so personally it's like you know
whatever it is that i've heard from the
other person it's not actually making me
a a worse person so let's see exactly
what you said the same things goes for
the or similar thing goes for
the
notion of being under your control and
you're up to you or not up to you
yeah
again that the idea there is not that if
something is not up to you therefore you
shouldn't care you shouldn't give you
know shouldn't try to do anything about
it it just means that
there are a lot of things the outcome of
which you ultimately do not control and
you should be always prepared mentally
to accept that in this particular case
let's say you know of course you want to
talk to the other person to your partner
and see if you can come up with an
agreement to a you know middle ground or
whatever but you have to be prepared for
the possibility that you can't in this
particular case that it may be that this
is one of those cases where he or she is
going to keep you know her position and
there is not much else you can do you
should try
but you should also be prepared for the
notion that you know it may not work and
and then you have to deal with the fact
that it might not work so it's i think
that's a lot a lot of it in this case in
this particular case i mean i do think
that there are actual problems with you
know certain notions and stories but i
don't think this is one of them i mean
this is mostly a matter of of language
and and the way in which these terms are
translated uh uh a lot a lot of the
times so
um you know and and something else i
think that we talked a lot about during
um
stoicon and i i always like to stress a
lot is stoicism
is
um a whole set of concepts whatever we
want to call them and they're like a
constellation you know
um you don't have a constellation when
you only have a few stars
or you if you have a constellation it's
a really mediocre crappy one
and so a lot of these ideas they people
take them as if they're absolutes like
the dichotomy of control the dichotomy
of control needs to be contextualized in
relation to a whole bunch of other
stoic ideas and it's it's difficult to
do that because it requires additional
learning and and you know but that's
what the virtual prudence is partly
about right being able to
harmonize these these different
ideas together and um
so
i think massimo you're right terminology
is a big problem i mean even cicero back
and yeah exactly
he was like yeah you stoics you know you
you bring in all this extra language
it's not helpful you know and then he'd
also say the aristotelians are saying
the same thing as you which i don't
really buy but um
no that's right i don't buy it either
but it's interesting you brought brought
up sister because that means that
already two thousand years ago right the
stoics had a problem with yeah
and of course cicero decided to invent
new words to just cover that right right
that's right he had he had other he had
precedent though and the starks were
already doing it yeah yeah we are we
have only a few more minutes uh uh
rob do you want to pick uh one question
yeah i did want to pick and i think this
might be a nice one to finish on and
this one's from alexander
um
is marriage and being married
part of living in agreement with nature
no
if you're just saying being married per
se
because you can have you can have a
crappy marriage you could i mean look at
half of our marriages end in divorce
um people get into marriages for the the
wrong reasons a good marriage is in
accordance with nature right and the
better the marriage is the more in
accordance with nature it is uh in
accordance with nature isn't like an on
off switch
it's it's something more like a uh like
a dimmer you know
except it's not dimming it's making
things brighter
what do you want to say andy i agree i
mean i think i think it can some days
are dim right some days are hard
it's because we're living together i
never i i never wanted to be married i i
didn't want any
piece of it uh but when greg and i
reconnected and fell in love i there was
no
question it was as if this kind of force
had come before right that that's that
was what our relationship was supposed
to be
but i agree a good marriage definitely
but a marriage on false pretense a
marriage where you can't grow with the
other person where you can't practice
kindness or
you know
share yourself is is a terrible thing
it's so much worse than you know being
alone because you bound yourself to this
person
um you know marriages do fail i mean
greg greg was married once before and if
his marriage hadn't failed we wouldn't
be married now um and i'm i'm glad that
we're together and i can have heartache
for his loss of that relationship too as
a person with compassion for him
you know that jug broke
um but
it out of it you know came something
good i mean his he's got wonderful
children i never wanted children like
things things work the way they're
they're
able to work if you bring
you know if you bring yourself to an
open space and that's one thing that has
i think allowed us to get through the
dim spaces is that the honesty even when
we disagree even when we're very angry
with one another even when we're not
practicing the things that we should be
practicing
there's no deception
and so i can trust that he understands
that i'm telling him exactly what i
think or feel he doesn't have to like it
but i'm adding that and i know he does
the same you know so for me yes that's
the kind of marriage that that is
great to have i wouldn't want anything
less
or else
you know we we have a a few more minutes
and i'd like to ask you a follow-up
question based on uh one of the another
one of the questions from the audience
this is from terry in in london
uh
terry says new discoveries are made
about human and animal nature daily for
example in evolutionary psychology
and uh different natures of males and
females across animals his toys isn't
flexible enough to deal with such
differences and the reason i brought up
this question is because we've been
talking about
according to nature and whatever what
that means that's that's a source of
confusion for a lot of people because
that there goes another problem with
language right
because often when i present the idea of
according to nature living according to
nature people say oh you mean that
whatever it's natural it's good and i
said no
yeah clearly i don't because that's a
that's a that's a basic logical fallacy
and it's very easy to disprove you know
there's all sorts of stuff that is
natural and it will kill you uh like
certain kinds of mushrooms for instance
so no don't that it doesn't mean that
whatever is natural is good and that's i
think greg is where you were going when
you said well it's not
marriage that it's natural also because
marriage doesn't exist in nature
obviously that's a human that's clearly
a human invention um it's a good
marriage that it's according to in
agreement with nature because in
agreement with nature i take it
for the stoic means in agreement with
reason and with human nature with human
pride yeah right so um so in that sense
then terry's question becomes
interesting it's like well but so what
if we discover
things in
you know evolutionary psychology uh
neuroscience etc that the ancient stoics
didn't know uh does that mean that we
should be doing things differently and
still according to nature
it means that we should be widening our
conception of what counts as natural so
i mean one one immediate thing to think
of is
you know the stoics approach to marriage
and what we've been talking about here
is very heteronormative um you know
andy's a woman i'm i'm i'm a man um i
mean we had that whole discussion about
like who's who's more you know
emotionally sensitive and all that but
but you know
gender wise we're we're sort of a
traditional couple
so what about um same-sex couples or you
know what about um
however we conceive of of attraction and
gender and sexuality i think we can
apply we don't have to say well anything
goes you know that would be ridiculous
because
there can be abusive relationships so
there can be
you know very exploitative relationships
or people can people can be in same-sex
couples
undergoing a similar sort of cultural
pressure to like you know fit in and do
that when it's not for them
but i think we would have to say all
right what's what's actually happening
within the scope of the relationship are
as you put it are the people developing
towards a fully realized human nature
together
you know and that might even include um
you know uh
marriages where there isn't any sex
going on you know uh you know what the
french used to call it mariage blanche
you know um
they're p asexual people might want to
get together and have a lifelong
partnership and it could have the same
sort of depth to it as
any other one so i i think yeah i don't
know i don't know that we have to like
look at like what we know about
other animals in order to get that i
think we we can just say listen um
stoicism is about being rational beings
um
what's the scope of rational beings you
know
right in fact i wouldn't look at at
other animals because the stoics are
pretty explicit that yeah we're talking
about human nature uh you know the
nature of a lion is a different thing um
and what is good for a lion is not good
for me necessarily and vice versa uh i i
would hate to like have to like you know
fight off my brothers in order to
run the pack and stuff like that because
i you know i like other i like other
people so
exactly so yeah what works for us
doesn't necessarily work for for other
species but i think the general notion
is that
uh
human nature
both imposes certain constraints on what
may or may not work uh right so there's
many different ways of having
relationships with other people there's
many different ways of having marriages
as you were pointing out a minute ago
and then there are some ways that don't
work and they don't work because
you know nobody likes to be abused it's
it's not right it's not according to
reason it's not agreement with reason
and with human nature to abuse somebody
else because nobody likes to be abused
and so if if that's the basis for your
relationship then that relationship is
in fact not in agreement with nature
even though you may be married and have
kids
uh you know maybe in fact less in
agreement with nature than a
relationship between two people who are
not married don't have kids and yet
treat each other as adults uh you know
with reason and compassion and and so
forth right so yeah
all right well we have done it um we got
to the to the end of the hour very
quickly as far as i'm concerned it just
went flying by so um andy greg thanks so
much for being with us uh tonight uh
this has been enlightening and and
interesting and all that and greg thanks
for coming the second time
i'm sure this is not going to be the
last one either but you know one of
these days we'll get you about something
else so so thank you very much thanks so
much to both of you i want to it's been
a great conversation thanks yeah thanks
for having us on it's but i really
enjoyed this me too thank you very much
great
you